Bonjour .
Je suis un hackeur.
Ayant une grande renommée mais aujourd'hui,
on va vivre une heure dans ma peau !
*Musique*
Ok yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie et welcome to the game .
Bienvenue dans le jeu c'est le putain de nom
du jeu . Aujourd'hui euh on va être dans la peau
d'un hackeur c'est parti new game j'ai * bafouille* j'ai pas tout compris à ce jeu !
Voila je préfère le dire, je vais pas faire le mytho !
Mais en gros, on va aller sur "Le deep web". Le deep web c'est quoi ?
C'est la partie invisible du web, là où il y'a tous les trucs
ghetto euh que Google etc ne référence pas.
Qui m'appelle ? Adam ! Ce qu'on cherche c'est
huit clefs cachées sur le deep
web . On peut pas les trouver sur tous les sites mais il y'a quelques
sites qui les ont ! On doit explorer chaque page.
Cliquer sur les liens et découvrir des trucs
Une clef cachée ressemble à ça ! On va donc
devoir trouver ces huit codes et les remettre dans l'ordre,
pour atteindre un site web hors du commun !
On est PARÉ avec notre grande expérience
de hacker ! Quand tu explore le deep web tu est exposé
face aux hackers ! Super ! Bah je vais les
contre atta-hacker ! Qu'on...
c'est compliqué ! AAA
OHHHHH ! Qui
me hacke ? Oh il faut faire quoi ? Faut
le diriger vers la sortie *Musique épique*
*Encore la musique épique*
Voila ! Allez !
Tu nous a pris pour qui ! Bon alors on peux aller sur le deep web bientôt
ou comment on fait !? OHHOHH ! NAN !
Putain ça va chier !!!
*Musique*
*Clap des mains* Voila ! Oh attend
un dernier truc que j'ai oublié de te dire . Je sais pas si c'est une légende ou pas mais...
Il est dit que plus tu vas profond
dans le deep web plus tu as de chance de te faire kidnapper par des mecs
qui vont te localiser.
Je les attendrai avec mon gros calibre.
Je l'ai pré-shot
Si tu penses que quelqu'un est en train de te traquer, juste, éteins les lumières de chez toi.
Ah bah d'accord ok, si on se fait kidnapper on fera ça.
Allez c'est parti on va aller dans le deep web.
Jean Michel. Non ?
M****. Ok il m'a mis une page d'accueil, donc ça
c'est la liste des sites dans le deep web.
On va devoir trouver des codes sur ces sites.
Premier site dans le deep web, ANN Hoster. Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
D'accord il marche pas. ANN Wallet ?
D'accord, ChosenAwake ?
Ah ok on doit, p***** on doit retrouver des codes là-dedans mec ?
Et sinon y a pas un code sur ce site ? Un code caché ?
Non y a que des formes bizarres de trucs improbables illuminati, y a rien, y a rien.
Oh ! Oh ! Oh mon dieu ! Oh mon dieu ! Oh mon dieu ! M**** ! Qui me hacke bordel !
Ok alors il va falloir l'amener vers le chemin.
*Musique*
On s'en est sortiiii ! D'où tu veux nous hacker, F-D-P !
DoubleUP. Ah Ah Ah Ah ! Ah mon dieu !
Oh non c'est chiant ça la ligne de code c'est dur.
pcapSlinger::pcapSlinger, mais c'est quoi ce signe bizarre !
Ok je l'ai fait, c'est bon. Yeaaaah !
Ok ça c'est fait hein, ne me demandez pas quelle est ma technique. Oh !
Bah ça va des armes ! Alors peut-être qu'il y a un truc caché ici.
Qu'est-ce qu'on prend, on prend un 9 mm ou un petit calibre 45 là c'est à voir ça !
*Musique*
*Clap* Ok Ok Ok !
Rien ne nous échappera. Oh non ne me dit pas que le code il va être caché dans tout ça ! Mais non vous êtes sérieux ?
MIJPAGW... Oh !
On l'a ! On l'a il est là !
Non non non non, c'est pas le moment de me hacker on avait trouver le code p***** !
*Musique*
Ok ok, alors on l'a, 1 - ec5a mon gars. ec5a. Yeaaaaah !
Tango Down, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Tout ce que vous devez savoir, c'est qu'on est une team extrêment entrainée d'anciens militaires.
Super les mecs qui vont me kidnapper dans une heure c'est ça ?
Il faut leur donner 25000$, ensuite ils font le job et ensuite il faut leur redonner 25000$. Et résultat,
des gens affreusement décédés, ou des photoshops extrêment bien réussis. On sait pas trop.
Non non, arrêtez ! Oh p*****.
*Musique*
Allez allez allez ! The Butcher c'est quoi ça ? Là c'est sûr il y a un code.
Y a un code quelque part, faut chercher, faut chercher.
Y a un bruit ! Y a eu un bruit !
J'éteins la lumière direct, j'éteins la lumière direct ! C'est quoi ce délire !
Y a eu un pas. Y a eu un pas dans la maison. Je suis terrifié.
C'est bon, c'est bon y a personne, on est bien, on est bien, allez on y retourne.
Tous les humains ne sont pas égaux, il y en a quelques uns qui sont nés supérieurs aux autres. D'accord
ça marche. Vraiment génial ce site. On veut des codes pour avoir accès à ce que Adam appelle la red room !
Qu'est-ce-que c'est la red room ? Trop de questions restent sans réponse.
Ok on continue, Weed Post c'est le dernier. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur Weed Post ?
Ah c'est pour commander de la weed, d'accord 10$ le gramme, quatre-...
Y a eu un bruit ? Y a eu un bruit.
P*****... 6 - b53f, là !
Regardez sur cette page on peut cliquer ici,
ici,
Ohhh... Y a un truc caché mec, y a un truc caché. Y a eu un bruit !
Y a un bruit p***** attends-tends-tends-tends.
Attends je suis à fond dans mon rôle de hacker là.
J'tu pourquoi ce mec ne peut pas éteindre la lumière de sa maison sans éteindre son PC, c'est complètement c** !
Allez on n'a pas de temps à perdre de toute façon personne ne viendra kidnapper un pauvre bolosse comme nous.
Donc là y a quoi, y a eu un bruit mec, y a eu un bruit, y a eu un bruit, y a eu un bruit !
Je suis en train de me faire kidnapper ! Y a un mec dans ma maison !
*Cri*
Aaah l'e***** ! Hé hé, on s'est fait avoir !
Ils pensent nous avoir si facilement, laissez-moi vous dire que non,
qu'avant qu'il me kidnappe, il faut que j'aille chez le coiffeur.
Nouvelle game, okkk ! On va trouver ces codes mon pote !
C'est reparti ! J'espère juste que ça change pas à chaque fois qu'on... bouge le jeu.
Ok, ça change à chaque fois qu'on bouge le jeu.
P***** tous les sites on change c'est plus comme tout à l'heure, je perds tous mes repères,
je suis comme La Fouine, je suis sans repère
Family Drug Shop, on mon dieu ! On peut acheter de l'héroïne, de la cocaïne, du speed,
plein de trucs cool pour faire des super vidéos
Oh, c'était là. 2... P***** les codes changent !
C'est sur cette page qu'on avait vu un code mais ça change !
fd32. fd32 c'est noté on l'a.
Suivant. NudeYoutubers. Oh mon dieu, des photos de youtubeurs nus !
P***** mais voilà ! Tout ce qui est intéressant ça marche pas !
Oh non le mec il fabrique des poupées, The Doll Maker
Oh non c'est glauque il fait des poupées !
Je crée des jouets qui sont en fait des femmes esclaves. Vous vous demandez comment ?
Non. Contactez-moi si vous en voulez une.
*Rire* T'as pas un code à la place ? Mais mec y a forcément un truc à faire avec le, avec le ChosenAwake.
Ah voilà c'est ça, suivant ensuite c'est quoi, faut que je trouve le bon sur lequel appuyer c'est ça en faite.
Ok c'est bon.
Oh non non non non non, c'était pas le moment, c'était pas le moment.
Ok alors c'est quoi l'énigme ? Oh mais mec c'est méga long c'est abusé !
*Musique*
Mec ça va nous amener où ça c'est quoi ce délire y a une énigme sur cette page !
Raah p*****...
*Cri*
Le mec, il a pas fait de bruit mon gars.
Déjà qu'est-ce qu'il faisait là, le mec il chassait un roucarnage dans mon jardin,
il a cru que c'était moi le roucarnage !
Mais je m'en bat les couilles, je joue pour un truc c'est résoudre l'énigme.
Le reste je m'en fous, le reste je m'en fous. Les codes, la red room, je m'en fous !
Oh l'énigme elle change à chaque fois ! P***** j'en ai marre...
Ok nickel.
Nickel,
oui !
Yes !
Suivant c'est quoi ?
Ouiii !
Oh p***** c'est quoi ce bordel. Oh mon dieu faut
cliquer sur l'un d'eux ? Ohhh
y a tellement de possibilités allez celui-là.
On a eu une URL
On a eu une URL, oh mon dieu si je la mets.
Pitié, c'est la fin du jeu ! The Deep Wiki II
Encore plus de sites web dans lesquels chercher pendant des heures sans rien trouver...
Vous savez quoi, vous savez que j'arrête d'être un hackeur, c'est dommage parce que j'étais hyper fort je sais,
et je vais devenir maçon, fabriquer des maisons dans lesquelles je serai plus à l'abri.
Non mais là risquer d'être kidnappé à tout moment,
et chercher des codes pendant des heures sur des sites perdus, ça va.
Ça va ! Moi je fais ma crise de hackeur de la trentaine.
Bon bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur Welcome to the game, bienvenue dans le jeu,
Mais dites-moi vous avez dit "bienvenue dans le jeu" mais on aurait préféré qu'ils nous disent tout de suite, "ne jouez pas".
Non mais le fond du jeu est bien, mais j'avoue que tu passes des heures à chercher des codes sur des sites web
et à un moment, t'es un peu saoulé.
Après le délire avec le mec qui vient et qui te kidnappe ça te fout la pression de vouloir sortir de son PC
AAAAHH !
Voila, ça c'est pas mal !
*Musique de fin*